先に述べたように、これらの音は
実際にこれら
の音と同じように発音されます。少し時間を取って
、鎌倉時代または
約800年前に、
これらの4つの文字がすべて
異なる音を表し、
これが破擦音を表し、これが
破擦音を表す理由について話します。 表現された
lystopDとこの表現されたBストップは、
これらの音が破擦音であり、
破擦音とストップが非常に異なる方法で明瞭に表現されていることを知っているので、これらの音はストップ
でした。
または約500年前、人々
はこれらの音をそれぞれ破擦音dと発音し始めまし
た。破擦音には破擦音が含まれているため
、これらの音と
これらの音の違いは劇的に縮小し、
人々
は中央のコミュニケーションと
リテラシーの欠如と混同し始めました。
混乱に追加された地域の方言 江戸
時代または約400年前、
これらのMVSは基本的に
スピーチと書面の両方で交換可能になり、
重なり始めて
最終的に同一になりました。これが
、今日、これらとこれらが
少なくとも標準的な日本語でまったく同じ発音を持っている理由です。
サダナとして知られて
いますもう少し歴史が
ありますこれらの音と文字の
融合は、作家、学者、政治家などにとって当然大きな問題になりました。
そのため
、初期の江戸時代から、
人々
はこれらのそれぞれをいつ使用するかについてのシステムやルールブックを求め始めました
キャラクター最後の主要なルールブック
自体は、1946年に再びdaikonazúcarの一部として、この改革の下で
今日も使用されている正書法または書法の改革の一部として登場しました。